gilles bernier bonjour m'entendez je
vous entends parfait alors le ministre
de l'environnement michel barny vous
n'aimez pas tellement qu'on lise mais
c'est parfois le ministre des
catastrophes malheureusement voilà il
n'ya pas encore catastrophe mais il ya
bien deux le ministre daniel bilalian ou
le miz la vie quotidienne donc la
qualité de l'air alors il ya on va
parler pollution tout de suite il ya
deux sujets qui ont été abordés juste
avant vous monsieur barnier c'est le
tunnel sous la manche je suppose que
vous n'étiez pas forcément au courant ce
qui s'est passé non j'ai entendu votre
information je pense que le musée
transport et de l'équipement donnera la
position du gouvernement s'il doit le
faire dans la journée
et bien alors deuxième chose les sens
l'essence sans plomb dont les taxes se
rattrape le super normal alors le
ministre de l'environnement que vous
êtes
est ce qu'ils trouvent ça normal il
n'est pas juste de dire que la fiscalité
de l'essence sans plomb rattrape ceux
qui m'apportez moi c'est qu'on garde une
différence sans doute là atterré
elle est réduite c'est la vérité parce
qu'il faut trouver de l'argent ne
racontons pas d'histoires aux gens qui
nous écoutent
il faut trouver de l'argent il faut
réduire les déficits je crois que chaque
citoyen a intérêt vraiment à ce qu on
réduit les déficits publics
mais ceux qui m'apportez mois comme il
environnement c'est qu'on garde une
différence et cette différence n'est pas
négligeable puisqu'elle reste de 20
centimes en faveur de l'essence sans
plomb bien alors revenons-en à ses
systèmes antipollution vous avez
inauguré ce matin il ya un rapport qui
est tout de même assez délicat qui est
en train de sortir monsieur barnier sur
la pollution à paris et une enquête très
sérieuse
on a pris une dizaine de jours par
exemple parents où il ya un peu plus de
positions d'habitude et on s'est aperçu
que ces jours-là y avait par exemple
chez les personnes qui sont déjà
handicapé bien entendu pas chez les bien
portants une augmentation de la
mortalité qui pouvait aller jusqu'à 5 %
une augmentation des hospitalisations
les arrêts de travail + 20 % aggravation
de l'asthme et de la sinusite la
pollution existe depuis le début du
siècle
autrefois c'était davantage le chauffage
et l'industrie maintenant on le voit ce
sont les transports notamment les
voitures et les camions qui sont à
l'origine de cette pollution
l enquête dont vous parlez a été faite
par la région ile de france
dans un souci de vérité entre 87 et 92
qu'est ce qu'elle montre elle montre en
effet que il y a un lien entre les pics
de pollution notamment l'été et les
soins apportés et les problèmes
rencontrés dans la santé de certaines
catégories de la population les enfants
les personnes âgées ou
personnes fragiles elle montre aussi que
certains polluants ont diminué notamment
ce qui est lié au dioxyde de soufre ou
aux poussières etc en revanche s'aggrave
certains autres polluants qui sont liées
au transport le co2 ou l'ozone voilà ce
qui me paraît important c'est de dire
que si la pollution existe depuis
longtemps
ce qui est nouveau c'est que maintenant
on le sait est que le gouvernement a
joué veut jouer la carte de la
transparence dire la vérité aux gens qui
sont devant leur poste en ce moment qui
conduisent leurs voitures qui sont dans
l'ordre dans leur maison ils ont le
droit de savoir si la qualité de l'air
est bonne ou si elle n'est pas bon alors
comment à partir du moment où on sait où
on dit la vérité je crois qu'on peut
mieux agit d alors justement les les
verts du conseil général de l'île de
france estiment eux que par exemple les
normes qui sont celles de paris sont
inférieures à celles de la communauté
européenne à savoir donc on
déclencherait les avertissements à paris
bien plus tard que si nous étions dans
une autre capitale bout contesté cette
affirmation goûter il ya quelques
différences dans dans les normes
mais nous nous rapprochons comme disait
d'ailleurs notre obligation de toutes
les directives européennes
moi je ne veux pas rentrer dans une
polémique avec les verts je pense que
les verts qui nous regardent devrait au
contraire approuvé être satisfait que
pour la première fois un gouvernement
joue à ce point la carte de la
transparence et de la vérité
nous mettons ici je suis sur la tour
eiffel un système qui n'existe nulle
part ailleurs dans aucune capitale du
monde
est ce que je veux dire aux français qui
nous écoutent c'est qu'au delà de la
région parisienne d'ici l'an 2000
si petite année si petite année le même
système de surveillance sera mise en
place dans toutes les agglomérations de
plus de 100 mille habitants en france et
non seulement on surveillera on
contrôlera mais on dira comme on le fait
ici par des bulletins météo si je puis
dire par des bulletins pollution dira la
vérité aux citoyens qui sont en même
temps des consommateurs tout à l'heure
vous avez donné votre bulletin météo moi
je veux que france 2 et puis les autres
chaînes alors d'amener le jeu suivant
diffuse un bulletin qualité de l'air en
même temps que bulletin est ce que vous
seriez prêt vous tout comme le brillant
l'afrique doit appuyer ces
éventuellement sur le bouton nucléaire
est ce que vous seriez prêt vous appuyez
sur le bouton arrêt partiel de la
circulation à paris ou dans une grande
ville si c'était nécessaire
bien entendu si nous atteignons à
plusieurs reprises le niveau 3 que vous
indiqué tout à l'heure il faudra prendre
des mesures dire aux gens fragiles de
rester chez eux et en même temps dire
aux gens de ne pas prendre leur véhicule
individuel mais au delà de la réaction
qu'on peut avoir dans l'urgence
moi je crois qu'il faut réduire à la
source la pollution c'est à dire avoir
des véhicules mieux contrôler et moins
polluant équipe est systématiquement de
pots catalytiques par exemple et puis
probablement mais c'est plus difficile
il faut du courage redistribue autrement
la circulation dans l'ain qu'il y ait
moins de voitures dans les villes encore
une chose hier dans le journal du
dimanche vous êtes attaqués à titre
personnel assez violemment à l'heure
d'été en disant ça sert plus à rien
alors qu'on nous avait dit dans les
années d'après 73 que c'était la panacée
qu'on allait économiser et gagner de
l'argent dans cette affaire et est-ce
que c'est toujours vrai ou est-ce que ça
vous semble contestable
ce n'est pas moi qui ai dit dans les
années soixante treize cette mesure
était prise pour des raisons liées au
choc énergétique aujourd'hui le bilan
énergétique est très contestable très
ambigu et j'observe en plus puisqu'on
parle de pollution que l'heure n'était
fait que paradoxalement aux pointes de
soleil il y a les pointes de transport
et donc à des phénomènes photochimique
qui aggrave la pollution dont jeu pour
le moins le bilan de l'heure d'été
contestable moi j'observe le
comportement les propres enfants qui
sont perturbés les personnes âgées de
certaines professions
donc je suis en effet à titre personnel
opposé à ces changements d'horaires nous
avons demandé et obtenu que la
communauté européenne fasse une étude
sérieuse approfondie dans trois ans une
décision définitive sera prise je
l'espère mois pour la suppression de
l'heure d'été
il nous reste une petite minute monsieur
barnier joue pause et même une question
politique j'en ai entendu parler
beaucoup pendant ce week-end on parle de
candidature udf de candidature et
repères on n'est plus dans la
candidature unique il ya toujours ceux
qui voudraient qu'on est con phase des
primaires pour qu'il y ait cette
candidature unique quelle est votre
position ou préférez quoi
moi j'ai toujours été favorable
proposition de charles pasqua demandant
qu'on sent la majorité pour les autres
partis aussi il ya des primaires pour
choisir un seul candidat je souhaite en
effet que nous soyons capables
cette fois ci parce que la france a
beaucoup de défis à affronter d'avoir un
seul candidat à l'élection
présidentielle mais c'est tout ce que je
peux dire parce que l'on choisit je vous
demande est demeurée monde et occuper de
nos ministères de travail et de ne pas
nous mêler trop tôt de la campagne
présidentielle
merci monsieur le ministre d'être resté
avec mercy beau